today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright welcome everybody we continue to
try to
on the daily show the podcast etc bring
you
sort of the latest news normally this is
not a program where if we wait 90
minutes
we might have something different to
report to you but because ballots are
still being counted
in a number of key states
in the presidential election and there
are even things still happening
at the senate level and house level
we're trying to figure out how to bring
you the latest information at whatever
time we do it and at this point in time
we do have changes to report to you from
where we were yesterday
no winner has yet been declared in the
presidential election between donald
trump and joe biden now i'm going to get
to the vote counts and to the scenarios
momentarily
but what you must understand is that
all of our worst worries about how
donald trump would react have happened
we covered some of them yesterday and we
will cover some more of them today
donald trump of course declaring victory
late tuesday early wednesday 2 a.m
saying we've won
yesterday donald trump and eric trump
and rudy giuliani and others
saying on twitter we won pennsylvania
pennsylvania has not yet been called and
the margin it continues to shrink
away from donald trump's favor and in
joe biden's favor although
trump still leads and i will show you
what those numbers are and the latest
which we will also be covering today
extensively is that
uh the trump campaign now claims to be
filing
multiple lawsuits in various states in
some states
we know that they've actually filed them
in others they've said they are filing
them although we don't actually know
and we have heard from joseph r biden jr
as well joe biden giving a short but
very appropriate and quite frankly very
presidential speech in wilmington
delaware yesterday so we are going to be
covering that
all of that being said let's now get
into the numbers and again i am going to
do a screen share with you guys this
seemed to work well
uh yesterday and give us um a pretty
good sense
of uh of of what is going on so let's
start there
first and foremost what has changed
since yesterday
wisconsin has been called for joe biden
with a less than one percent margin of
victory
donald trump says he has filed for a
recount there
and is emailing supporters asking for
money to fund
that recount michigan has also been
called for joe biden
and in fact as we get slightly updated
numbers literally as we're speaking
michigan now uh about two and a half 2.7
points in favor of joe biden
a bigger margin of victory in both
michigan and wisconsin actually
wisconsin is basically the same margin
of victory that trump had over hillary
in 2016 a larger margin of victory for
joe biden
in michigan this year than what donald
trump had over hillary clinton
in 2016. what is still oh before we go
any further
alaska has still not been called
although
we know it will go for donald trump
currently leading two to one
almost with half the vote reporting
they're just slow to count there a lot
of rural areas but we're going to
continue tracking and following that of
course but
in my count i am already giving those
three electoral votes to donald trump
in the meantime arizona is a source of
some controversy and later in today's
program i'm going to bring you video
of a trump supporters gathering at the
capitol in phoenix arizona
and then sort of moving over and joining
another protest at the maricopa county
election center i believe it's called
where they are demanding that
they count the vote and they are mad at
fox news because not only the associated
press
which is what what we are using here but
also fox news
um called arizona although there are
people who feel it is still too
close with 88 reporting joe biden is up
by 2.4 there about 68 and a half
thousand
votes so what does the race hinge on
if we grant joe biden arizona which
most but not all currently do it hinges
on the states of nevada pennsylvania
north carolina and georgia and again
conceding arizona to joe biden would put
him at 264 electoral votes
meaning a win in any of these four
outstanding states
um and joe biden would be the next
president of the united states
the least likely for me is north
carolina
north carolina now the the vote count
has not actually
moved for a full 24 hours we are not
exactly sure why
but north carolina is stuck at 94
reporting
the lead for donald trump right now is
about 1.4 percentage points
which is equal to about 80 000 votes
i am not counting on north carolina
flipping to joe biden
following that joe biden is currently
leading in nevada
now the vote count in nevada yesterday
stopped being updated
relatively early and it had joe biden up
seven tenths of a point
that lead has now expanded as nevada
again this is as of this moment
as nevada has gone back to counting and
reporting votes
joe biden's lead has gone from seven
tenths of a point
to nine tenths of a point the path
for biden to win is that a majority an
important amount of the remaining votes
are from the vegas area which went for
hillary clinton in 2016
anticipating it would go for joe biden
now that's the argument for nevada
with those six electoral votes joe biden
would get to 270 presuming nothing
changes in arizona which has been called
we then have the very curious case of
pennsylvania
and to explain what's happening in
pennsylvania
um understand that this was the
red mirage scenario state
pennsylvania does not start counting
mail-in ballots until the polls
close on election day pennsylvania
expected to have
favorable numbers for trump and
in-person voting favorable numbers for
joe biden
in vote by mail and indeed on election
night
donald trump had a lead of eight even
nine or ten points
thinking back to different moments on
election night and over time that lead
started to shrink
yesterday when i came to you uh joe
biden was down about
seven points in pennsylvania and now
as the vote has been counted as you can
see here with this very interesting
chart from the new york times that i'm
showing people as the vote count has
gone
trump's biggest lead was right at about
55
as the vote count has increased it has
narrowed narrowed narrowed
now considered 1.8 points
by the new york times and officially
according to the associated press
also 1.8 points separating donald trump
and joe biden
that is about 116 000 vote lead for
trump
the path here for biden if you believe
there is one
is that there are a bunch of ballots
from pittsburgh which cannot even
legally be counted until tomorrow
and that as the philadelphia votes
continue to be counted the margins will
continue to shrink for donald trump and
maybe flip to joe biden of course
if joe biden wins pennsylvania he wins
the election we then have georgia
as you can see in georgia also donald
trump's biggest lead
coming right around 33 percent of the
vote being counted
from that point forward as more and more
of the vote has been counted
donald trump's lead has shrunk and
shrunk and shrunk
to the point that his lead is now a mere
0.3 percentage points
or about 13 500 votes
we have 99 reporting in georgia so
the at this point i don't even want to
go into the various models claiming to
know
how likely is it that it would go one
way how likely is it that it would go
the other way it's extraordinarily close
and if indeed it is the atlanta ballot
that remains
out it could get even closer
and maybe joe biden could win it or
maybe not so it is now down to these
four states now it goes without saying
as i pull up the map if we give arizona
to joe biden as the associated press has
done
oh sorry and utah of course is a trump
state as i mentioned earlier even though
officially alaska has not been called
for donald trump i am calling it for
donald trump because it will ultimately
go for donald trump
if joe biden were to win nevada that
would put him at 270 electoral votes and
this would be over
barring of course recounts and lawsuits
which donald trump is
doing if joe biden were to flip
pennsylvania
that would put him at 284 electoral
votes also 270
above 270 and it would secure this
election
if georgia were to flip to joe biden
that would put him at 280 electoral
votes
again securing a an electoral victory
and if north carolina flips to joe biden
that would also put him at 279 although
i i believe north carolina is the
least likely to flip so we the range of
scenarios that are remaining
are if trump wins all four of these
states
trump wins re-election with 274
electoral votes imagine that arizona
were wrong
that could put donald trump at 285. if
arizona stays with biden
the best biden could do if he were to
get all four remaining states nevada
pennsylvania north carolina and georgia
it would put joe biden at 321 electoral
votes i don't think there's any way
that biden gets north carolina so for me
the biggest real possibility for biden
would be 306
i don't particularly think he gets
georgia either
and so if biden were to get nevada and
pennsylvania
joe biden would win with 290 my
prediction was
295 so that could be very very close
without nevada joe biden would have 284
with nevada instead of pennsylvania joe
biden would have exactly 270 electoral
votes and if that is the case
the proportional apportionment in
nebraska
could be the difference maker joe biden
got one electoral vote
from the second district in nebraska if
indeed this comes down to nevada and joe
biden doesn't get pennsylvania
doesn't get georgia doesn't get north
carolina
biden will have 270 thanks to
that one vote from nebraska without it
it could be the 269 to 269 tie scenario
we've been talking about
with it and nevada joe biden would win
270 to 268.
we may know more by tonight we may know
more by tomorrow
again checking in on the latest numbers
in pennsylvania with the latest update
still a 1.8 percentage point lead for
donald trump as votes are being counted
in georgia a 0.3 percent lead
for donald trump with 99 reporting
and in nevada with 76 reporting and more
vote expected there today
a lead of 0.9
for joe biden in the state of nevada now
i don't even want to get ahead of myself
at this point
there are lots of people who are very
confident that joe biden is going to win
there are also very a lot of people
including trump's entire family who
claim that trump has won they believe
trump
really won nevada they believe trump won
georgia they believe trump won
pennsylvania they even believed
trump won michigan and even potentially
wisconsin some of them are saying so
all we can do at this point in time is
wait
in the senate it is increasingly looking
like democrats are not going to take the
senate
now this was my prediction
until very recently at which point i
said there is a path for democrats in
the senate
but you might recall that for the last
three years i've been saying
based on what's up in the senate in 2020
i don't think democrats have a shot my
belief was
2020 has to be the year of taking the
presidency
and 2022 may be the year of democrats
taking the senate
because of some very favorable polling
and the feeling of momentum
over the last couple of months there was
a credible path for democrats to take
the senate it's conceivable it could
happen but it is not looking
particularly likely but a very
interesting senate race
is in georgia in georgia incumbent
republican david perdue
appeared to be winning easily in a
three-way race
most prominently against democratic
challenger john ossoff
as of right now david perdue the
incumbent republican in georgia is
hovering
right at the 50 mark in terms of the
vote in georgia
this is relevant because given that it's
a three-way race
if no candidate gets a majority of the
vote meaning if david perdue ends up
with 49.9 percent or 49.8 percent of the
vote
there would be a runoff between purdue
and ossoff the second place
challenger um and that would be a brand
new senate race and potentially a seat
that could be flipped could be flipped
so we're going to be watching that and
then of course we're also looking at the
numbers in the house
i'm going to tell you right now we don't
have to do it now i am not going to
participate in the stuff of now
as it's looking okay for biden and you
know knock on wood
there are already leftists starting to
criticize joe biden
we're going to take things a step at a
time we'll criticize joe biden if he
becomes president and does things we
don't like
okay we're not getting into that where
at some point
we will have to have a real
um uh not not a maya culpa but a real
accounting
for the problems of the democratic party
is that
um it is pointed to by the house numbers
is the point that i'm making um
many predictions saying oh democrats are
going to dramatically expand their lead
in the house of representatives and it
does not yet appear as though that is
happening although
in 2018 we had to wait a little while
for that to be adjudicated but
there is no question that we we have to
be able to hold two
ideas in our head at the same time on
the one hand
yes many trumpists are ignorant yes many
trumpists are uninformed
many are not good people many see
themselves as fighting
a war as i said yesterday where facts
don't matter and they must defend their
leader no matter what
that is true and so part of why
republicans did not get crushed the way
some
some predicted has to do with trumpists
but we have to be able to at the same
time say
if the democratic party faced with
arguably the most incompetent president
in the modern political era
arguably the worst major country
responds to the pandemic
in the world complete mishandling of the
economy
on and on and on if given all of that
democrats end up losing seats in the
house
we can't just blame trumpus and that's
exactly how democrats will continue to
lose if they say it's just
stupid trumpus because it's not it's
partially stupid trumpists
the democratic party has responsibility
and we're not going to get ahead of
ourselves but
maybe it'll be tomorrow maybe it'll be
monday
maybe it'll be the following month i
don't know when it's going to be
but i am taking notes i have copious
notes as some like to say
about the failings of the democratic
party
and there will be a time for that so i
know people have started emailing me
saying david why aren't you talking
about this that the other thing about
the
the democratic it's not time yet is it
we do things when they're when it is the
time to do it i
i even got emails this morning from
people saying how do you see 2024
no guys no when in 2017 people asked me
about
2020 i said we've got a midterm first we
need to focus on the midterm
we are not even done with this election
yet so we are going to take it a step at
a time as i always insist that we should
be doing glad you're with us today i
will be live later today i hope you will
join me on youtube twitch and facebook
with continued results
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about trump's
lawsuits we will talk about rudy
giuliani and eric trump's stunt
in philadelphia we will talk about
trump's spiritual advisor
um uh i guess trying to strike out the
demons that may be preventing donald
trump from winning we have all of it
and i want to hear what is on your mind
i am on twitter at d
pacman make sure you're following me
there the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump had a complete
authoritarian tirade on twitter
yesterday
as his leads in a few states started to
diminish
and with those leads the possible path
to 270 electoral votes started to narrow
for donald trump
now remember that this is all after
donald trump
already declared victory at 2 a.m early
wednesday morning quick reminder of what
that looked like he already said he won
so we won there we lead by 76
000 votes with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and we as far as i'm
concerned we already have for it
so i just want to thank you now we
warned at the time about the red mirage
scenario we talked about the red mirage
scenario
uh prior to the election and i warned
you that because of the
mail-in ballot volume that is expected
and the rules in some states like
pennsylvania where they cannot
even start counting the mail-in ballots
until the polls have closed
we should be aware and be cautious that
an early trump lead in some states may
not
endure and case in points we saw
wisconsin shift from a trump lead to a
biden
uh win we saw michigan shift from a
trump lead to a biden win and we're
watching other states as of this time
trump loses it and his tweets were so
weaponized in terms of spreading voting
disinformation
about the election that most of them
were flagged by twitter
take a look at this trump saying quote
last night i was leading
often solidly in many key states in
almost all instances democrat run and
controlled
then one by one they started to
magically disappear
as surprise ballot dumps were counted
very strange and the pollsters got it
completely and historically wrong and
twitter warning
summer all of the content in the street
is disputed and it might be misleading
about an election trump then tweeting in
all caps
what is this all about about a post from
matt walsh
about some supposed injustice in another
tweet
which has since been deleted altogether
what the hell's going on we don't know
trump then tweeting they are finding
biden votes all over the place
in pennsylvania wisconsin and michigan
so bad for our country
now by finding he means counting legal
votes
as the process is supposed to go you
receive
votes you look at who they voted for and
you credit them to the appropriate
candidate trump again tweeting how come
every time they count
mail-in ballot dumps they are so
devastating
in their percentage and power of
destruction
because we knew from day one
that the in-person votes would favor
trump in many states
but the mail-in votes would favor joe
biden you could
really see trump crumbling with it each
tweet going on to say
quote they are working hard to make up a
500 000 vote advantage in pennsylvania
disappear
asap likewise michigan and others and
twitter again warning
this may be misleading about an election
trump tweeting we are winning
pennsylvania big
but the pa secretary of state just
announced there are millions of ballots
left
uncounted left to be counted which of
course just means
a lot of people voted and you've got to
count those votes and then trump
tweeting and this may be the the
sort of like peak insanity trump saying
we have claimed
for electoral vote purposes the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
the state of georgia and the state of
north carolina
each one of which has a big trump lead
additionally we hereby claim the state
of michigan
if in fact there was a large number of
secretly dumped
ballots as has been widely reported
trump claiming states that at the time
he hadn't won
and moments later michigan was actually
called
for joe biden trump authoritarian
nightmare
crumbling before our very eyes i even
got some messages from some conservative
friends
in the southeast of the united states
who said trump seems to be going crazy
like i'm for low taxes
and i don't like business regulation but
trump seems to have lost his mind
uh and a bunch of people from the
southeast who who didn't even vote at
all interestingly enough
wrote to me saying that we will see what
trump's mental health looks like later
today
now as a total contrast to what donald
trump was doing on twitter yesterday joe
biden gave a speech as votes continued
to be counted
as donald trump was imploding on twitter
claiming states for himself
that hadn't been called demanding votes
not be counted in certain states
and be counted in other states depending
on where they are
joe biden gave an actual presidential
speech
which was completely normal and boring
in wilmington delaware
but as a contrast to what we've seen for
the last four years
actually was surprising in that it
reduced the temperature
it did not call for people to make
claims that couldn't yet be backed up
it united people just take a look at
this it'll be time for us to do what
we've always done as americans
to put the harsh rhetoric of the
campaign behind us
to lower the temperature to see each
other again
to listen to one another tweet to hear
each other
again and care
for one another to unite
to heal to come together as a nation
i know this won't be easy i'm not naive
neither of us are
i know how deep and hard the opposing
views are
in our country on so many things but i
also know this as well
to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies we are not enemies
what brings us together as americans is
so much stronger
than anything that can tear us apart and
importantly during this speech
joe biden also pointed out
he believes he is on the path to 270 at
the time he believed it
he says in the speech i'm not declaring
victory
and then issues this message of coming
together very important moment where he
says this
now after a long night of counting
it's clear that we're winning enough
states
to reach 270 electoral votes needed to
win the presidency
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners so we
were watching this live during a stream
yesterday and joe biden actually says
i believe we will have the votes to win
but i am not declaring victory
there was plenty of reporting that was
saying he did declare
a victory there including this whopper
of a headline from the bbc
the bbc tweeted trump and biden each
claim victory as lawsuits brew
biden literally said i'm not declaring
victory what could biden have said
beyond i am not claiming victory to make
that more clear biden issued this
completely generic
we believe we will prevail when all the
votes are counted
everybody says that and the bbc says
well it's just like trump claiming
victory no
trump actually went out at 2 a.m eastern
time on election night and said we've
won
trump tweeted and eric trump tweeted and
rudy giuliani tweeted we've won
pennsylvania when they had not won it at
that point in time
and yet he still joe biden can't get
away from these false headlines that say
hey they've both claimed victory
no they have not and remember donald
trump we looked at this tweet
in the earlier segment trump tweeted
yesterday we have claimed
the commonwealth of pennsylvania the
state of georgia
and the state of north carolina and we
hereby claim the state of michigan if in
fact there was a large number of
secretly dumped ballots
as has been widely reported in any case
we already
have to be careful about false reporting
about
what joe biden is saying and what joe
biden is doing
but what a contrast between how joe
biden spent the last 24 hours
and how donald trump did donald trump
spent the day
filing lawsuits which we will talk about
sending eric trump and rudy giuliani to
pennsylvania to claim
everything's fraudulent tweeting that
he's claiming states that he hasn't
actually won
and saying in some cases the ballots
need to stop being counted
and in other cases the ballots need to
start being counted in order to
justify his continued path to biden
spoke for five minutes
is allowing all votes to happen isn't
telling anybody to stop counting
reduced tensions and said if he has a
path to 270 that ultimately prevails
he will be everyone's president if he
wins you don't have to agree with joe
biden's policy on taxation
you don't have to believe that joe biden
is going to be the best on health care
to acknowledge that this reduction of
the temperature
and a return to sanity is exactly what
is needed at this time and as a reminder
again
record coronavirus cases yesterday
a lot has been going on the last 48
hours so the coronavirus news has
diminished
but there were 108 000 cases in the
united states yesterday this is the most
coronavirus cases in a single day since
the start of the pandemic
there were 1200 deaths and that number
continues to climb as reports from
yesterday are finalized
we need to deal with the pandemic and
when i see one guy tweeting
stop counting here start counting there
i've won
i'm claiming michigan i'm claiming
pennsylvania and then i see the other
guy say
i believe we have a path to victory and
if i get it
i will be everyone's president because
we are at unprecedentedly difficult
times
it's very clear which one we need right
now and i know
that there are millions of republicans
who recognize that
not all of them not nearly all of them
but there are millions of republicans
that recognize
that that is what we need right now
we'll have more about this
on our instagram page make sure you're
following us at david pakman show on
instagram
and while you're there follow me on
instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube
at youtube.com forward slash the
davidpakman show
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform at
steemit.com david pakman
that's s t double e m i t dot com
forward slash at david pakman
welcome back to the david pakman show
i really hate that so many predictions
have come true this week because of what
it means about the state of our
democracy
um before there was any victory to claim
this week donald
trump said at 2am on friday on tuesday
night
early wednesday morning that he won the
election then he started with the claims
that it was rigged
about votes being found all claims which
were flagged by twitter as potentially
misleading about an election
and now donald trump is starting with
lawsuits the vote count resumed in
pennsylvania yesterday
and as this was happening donald trump's
personal lawyer rudy giuliani
and donald trump's one of donald trump's
sons eric trump went to philadelphia to
announce major action
to stop the terrible cheating and vote
counting that was going on at the time
it is not lost on me that in some cases
donald trump was saying we must stop
counting
votes in other places donald trump was
saying we must continue counting votes
and so were his supporters and we'll get
to some of that video
but first rudy giuliani's explanation
is complete and total incoherence saying
that he will file
two lawsuits and a federal lawsuit
and maybe a national lawsuit i i can't
even get through this with a straight
face
take a look at this insanity and i
challenge you to tell me what
on earth is rudy talking about 100 000
fraudulent meaningless paper ballots
that no one gets to observe
so we are going to continue the lawsuit
here we're going to bring a second one
and then we're going to bring a federal
lawsuit and we're going to take a very
good look at whether
we bring this nationally we certainly
are going to bring it here and in
wisconsin
quite possibly we'll do a national
lawsuit and really expose the corruption
of the democrat party but this is beyond
anything i've ever seen
before this comes when you think you
have so much power
and you own the media that you can do
anything you want
well sorry we're going to fight for the
people we're going to vindicate
their right and the ultimate result is
president trump has won pennsylvania
he's going to vindicate people he's
filing for lawsuits this is maybe rudy
giuliani's most humiliating moment
and i've seen the borat scene for people
to be uh
to understand i'm including that as well
it's a deranged person
making no sense or trump put him up to
it and he feels like he can't say no
that's the only other explanation i can
imagine so
in an attempt to tell you what is
actually going on
and just as a reminder many times people
say they are filing a lawsuit and they
don't
i'm just saying when rudy says on a whim
i'm filing two to four
lawsuits let's verify that the lawsuits
have actually been fired filed but the
the claim is that trump's campaign
is filing lawsuits to stop the counting
of ballots in michigan
and pennsylvania as they are demanding
increased
access to observe the tallying process
at a bunch of locations in these key
states
a trump and the georgia republican party
have also filed a lawsuit in georgia
we don't know why we don't know for what
we don't yet know
exactly who they are suing there at
least as of the time that we went to
record today
maybe by now we know what that lawsuit
is about the trump campaign also said
that the lawsuit demands
the the michigan lawsuit or the
pennsylvania one or both
demands that they want to review ballots
which were opened and counted
without them having meaningful access
and of course what that means we don't
know now the the sort of funny
thing or perverted thing depending on
your perspective
is when trump announced that they were
doing this he was losing michigan
and ultimately michigan was straight up
called for biden
so my instinct you might say why would
you stop counting
when you're losing like in michigan in
pennsylvania he wants to stop counting
while he's winning as of the time of
that announcement my
thought is the stop the count is sort of
um an intermediate measure
meant to give them more time to come up
with something else
count the vote stop the count
temporarily
and then figure out what's the next
claim that you're going to make but
there was actually
an even better moment during this and we
caught it
live during my stream yesterday and i
want to get to that next
okay this clip i'm going to play for you
is one of my favorite clips in my entire
time doing the david pakman show
as i already told you rudy giuliani went
to philadelphia yesterday with eric
trump they announced that they're filing
two
maybe three possibly even four lawsuits
just related to pennsylvania
they're filing lawsuits in michigan
later we learned they're filing lawsuits
in georgia
they're suing everybody okay fox news
carried
this event with eric trump and rudy
giuliani and it was during the neil
cavuto show
what i am about to show you is almost
performance art
as rudy is ranting incoherently about
pennsylvania
fox cuts in they interrupt rudy giuliani
and they announce
joe biden has won the state of michigan
which potentially would make
pennsylvania irrelevant at the time we
didn't yet know
you have to see it it's video poetry
shortly after rudy says joe biden might
have voted 50 times
he might have voted 5 000 times it's
just
perfect and pay attention to when they
go back to rudy
after calling michigan for biden rudy
then has taken out a manila folder
and papers are popping out of it you
can't make
a satire of this it is performance art
we have no idea if they're signed if
they're postmarked properly
if it isn't just the same person who
submitted a hundred thousand ballots
and they all got counted
this is the way they intend to win now
i'm informed by
former congressman sweeney who's been we
are considering amanda rudy giuliani you
might have noticed something happened to
the electoral vote count for joe biden
our decision desk
has taken a look at michigan and
concluded joe biden has won
michigan and gets the 16 electoral votes
from michigan that puts him now six
electoral votes
from the presidency of the united states
nevada could do it
those electoral votes are still out
there when you know there's six
electoral votes there if he were to take
that state
he would be at 270 and he would be on
his way to the white house
now back to the legal challenges being
mounted
as we speak by team trump
you make sure that it's properly
postmarked
you make sure you make sure that it's uh
properly addressed
and then you pass on it this really i
mean
that should be in a museum of like some
kind of
avant-garde art or something that
70-second video clip is just
remarkable emblematic of
everything about donald trump sends rudy
out to rant and rave
about two three or four lawsuits maybe
joe biden voted five
thousand times and as he's doing it the
reality of joe biden winning michigan is
announced it it's just perfect
and to step back a little bit how would
this election have gone
differently maybe if rudy had focused
less on
conspiracies about hunter biden and the
supposed laptop from hell and
instead focused on just winning more
states it is difficult to believe
or even have recommended months ago to
trump hey you know what if you deal with
the virus you might easily get
re-elected which is what happened
in new zealand and in some other places
it's hard to believe that at one point
rudy was sort of respected
here's one more clip from this strange
event
rudy and eric trump listen to eric trump
here
we're gonna win pennsylvania but they're
trying to cheat us out of it because
they know it's their only path to
victory
they know it's the only path to victory
and so we came here today we met with
all our lawyers
we are going to file suit in
pennsylvania it's a shame that we have
to do that it's the last thing that we
wanted to do it's the last thing my
father wanted to do
but this is rampant corruption and it
can't happen it simply can't happen it's
not fair this isn't
democracy it's really amazing how these
people have a knack for
saying nothing but talking so mouth i
see the mouth moving
i hear words coming out but they are
saying absolutely nothing i mean this is
against democracy eric trump says what
is against democracy
that you're not sure whether biden
didn't vote five thousand times that's
the against democracy
and it's becoming very much like uh
donald trump's obama gate where when
he's asked
yeah okay obama gate the biggest
political crime in history
what is the crime and what law was
broken trump says
you know what it was or it was treason
or
they spied on my campaign or whatever
lots of these people if donald trump
ultimately loses
i hope then they retire and we never see
them again minutes before i went live uh
to to record today
donald trump's press secretary kaylee
mckennany tweeted
is anybody interested in joining a live
prayer group tomorrow i mean
they're resorting to prayer now to try
to win this election
and by the way after the break
i have video of donald trump's white
house spiritual advisor
trying to speak or not trying to
speaking in tongues
in an attempt to i guess rid the votes
of demonic possession
i i can't guys let's just go to a break
and i'll explain it to you afterwards
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what
pat does all day very very concerning to
a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account
at david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay you guys have to see this this is
going to give you sort of a glimpse into
how sick and deranged
a huge part of the country is trumpists
started
swarming a vote counting location at the
tcf
center in detroit michigan yesterday to
furiously
and defiantly and outrageously demand
that votes not be counted now
simultaneously they were swarming
arizona polling places saying count
votes
we'll get to that later the hypocrisy we
need a little more time for
check this out this is video from
annelise frank on twitter
and yes the chant you are about to hear
is stop
the vote
people weren't just outside here is a
picture from the same annalise frank
reporter in detroit
from inside and as she describes it
these trumpets were yelling about
election integrity and how votes should
stop being counted
immediately here's more video of these
stop the count
that chants stop that counts
do you realize how mind-numbingly
stupid we look to every country
around the world we look like idiots
and there's a lot to what happened
yesterday in detroit it was not a
spontaneous demonstration chad living
good who's a reporter in detroit as well
posted a screenshot of an email that was
sent yesterday morning by a so-called
coalition's director named sean mosinski
which went out to republican voters
telling them
come to the tcf center in detroit to be
vote challengers
and then this is exactly what went down
and the right
seems to think that it is some kind of
radical leftist idea to
count every legal ballot in a democracy
donald trump retweeted just moments ago
i don't have this for you but you can
find it on his twitter
a statement from the nevada attorney
general adam laxalt
claiming that hey listen if it weren't
for mail-in ballots in nevada
trump would have won which of course
ignores that mail-in ballots
are legal ballots in the sense that they
are ballots from voters who vote
it's unbelievable the perversion of
democracy that they so casually attempt
and when this is all said and done i am
really interested
in what the talking points will be when
people
mention that counting ballots
is part of democracy not a perversion of
it and republicans
desperately try to stop the counting of
votes
it's going to be some version of well we
weren't allowed to
look at each ballot we don't know if
those were legitimate ballots
or they were just finding fake ballots
that's sort of the argument we heard
rudy giuliani make yesterday
conservatives will claim that they were
just trying to make sure all the ballots
were legitimate and
every time you know for the last four
years it's happened what a hundred times
that i find myself wondering
how are they going to justify this
absurdity that this is beyond
justification trump with the sharpie on
the hurricane map or what
this this one has to be beyond
justification
and then i look in the comments sections
in the pro-trump
enclaves of the internet and then i say
oh that's how they're going to justify
it okay
they always found a way and in fact i
keep reading comments from trumpists
talking about
deadlines for ballots that they think
are being violated
the deadlines for counting votes
are decided at the state level the
states that are still
counting haven't reached the deadline
it's very simple the only constitutional
deadline
is that by december 14th when the
electors
officially vote the count must be done
people who don't support democracy do
this
now meanwhile in detroit you had stop
the count
protesters in michigan in i'm sorry
in arizona you had start the count
protesters and we're going to talk about
that next
okay so yesterday we have michigan
pro-trump protesters gathering to demand
that votes not be counted in arizona
armed pro-trump protesters gathered
to demand that votes be counted and to
attack fox news
this is just unbelievable here's video
from simon romero he's a correspondent
for the new york times
you will see if you're watching you
won't hear this but you'll see
that one guy is armed with a long gun
you will hear
chance of shame on fox which i will
explain in a moment
[Music]
so shame on fox refers to
fox calling arizona for joe biden
and trumpists i guess are furious about
that
the associated press also called arizona
for joe biden here's another video
this is still in phoenix where a chant
of fox
a chant of fox news sucks breakout take
a look at this
a lot of people in the crowd are are not
wearing masks we're
we're keeping a respectful distance but
a loud and very boisterous crowd
you'll start hearing them start up here
and they're actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because fox
news
called arizona for biden yesterday
and a lot of people are angry about that
we have not called
arizona a lot of other so the protesters
then moved
from the capitol in phoenix the site
of that last video to the maricopa
county recorders building where they
started chanting
stop the steal naturally you will notice
almost not a single mask in sight
[Applause]
we need oversight to verify that each
person who voted is
here's another video where you can't
really tell who's saying what
other than you do hear the term mail in
ballots at one point
[Applause]
these protests are not only pathetic on
principle
but the added layer is that there are
almost no masks the united states had a
hundred and eight
thousand new cases yesterday more than
twelve hundred
new deaths yesterday and they're not
only protesting who the hell knows what
there's also barely a mask in sight as
simon romero
also reported as time went on the number
of guns went up as well as you can see
in this next picture we're showing the
open
carry a handgun guy with a trump hat
then here is an armed pro-trump
protester
in full gear reportedly named rich 30
years old with an ar-15
he was mad according to simon romero who
interviewed him mad about biden wanting
to quote
tax guns how ironic
or tragic is it that the very monsters
out there protesting and angry at fox
news
we're partially created by fox news i
think that that's something we we should
not
we should the the irony and tragedy of
that should not be lost on us now sadly
when people show up armed and wreak
havoc
it does have an effect maricopa county
in arizona
had to close down its ballot counting
facility to the media and to the public
now
the the it was open to the people
counting votes the vote count continued
but because of this heavily armed group
gathering outside the building we have
seen
the building have to be closed down to
the public and to the media
fortunately the votes will still be
counted now by the way
is there any chance that these guys
mostly guys
will be tear gassed and told to disperse
when 9 pm comes like the black live
matter protesters
all over the country during the summer
no not particularly likely
do these domestic terrorists want the
votes counted or not i'm having trouble
keeping track but of course the reality
is
you have to understand the trumpian view
if the counting might help
trump they want the votes to be counted
if the counting might
hurt trump they don't want the votes to
be counted don't you understand guys
al-qaeda says count votes that are good
for us
don't count votes that are bad for us
and that's as simple as it
it really is that simple you have to see
this video
this is a great side story as donald
trump has been melting down on twitter
as his children and rudy giuliani have
been melting down at press conferences
donald trump's spiritual advisor paula
white
led a prayer service to i guess fight
off the demons that might prevent
donald trump from winning i am going to
issue a warning i would
get if you're watching with kids today
get the kids out of the room if you're
listening with kids maybe put some
put some headphones in this is extremely
disturbing
it will contain graphic video indicative
of
severe untreated maybe even undiagnosed
mental illness
here is paula white striking and
striking and striking down
i guess demons so that trump will get
reelected
she then starts speaking in tongues
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike until you
have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would strike the ground for you
will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of shouting and singing i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of an abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of an abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
the lord says it is done the lord says
it is done
the lord says it is done for i hear
victory
victory victory victory in the quarters
of heaven in the quarters of heaven
victory victory victory victory victory
victory victory
for angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched
[Laughter]
for angels have even dispatched from
africa right now
africa right now africa right now from
africa right now they're coming here
they're coming here in the name of jesus
from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa from
south america
angelic forces angelic reinforcement
angelic reinforcement angelic
reinforcement
pikahata anda ata or bhattarata
and for i hear the sound of victory
now obviously i'm not going to analyze
the specifics of what she's saying
but this is someone who donald trump has
given actual prominent
placement at the white house for various
religious events i like how she
talks about dispatched angels from
africa to help trump
i hope they're not coming from s-hole
countries because they're not going to
be allowed in it's going to be trouble
then paula white battles the demonic
confederacy that are trying to steal the
election from trump also i don't know if
you noticed in the first clip if you
were watching
there's a guy who keeps walking back and
forth behind paula white
holding papers or a book who's that guy
what's he doing just every detail here
is hilarious
we break and divide every demonic
confederacy against the election against
america
against that who you have declared to be
in the white house
we break it up in the name of jesus we
lose confusion into every demonic
confederacy
directed right now at this election
directed specifically at the six states
we come against people that are working
in
high levels right now with demonic
confederacies
and secrecies and demonic plans and
networks we break it up and we command
them to be exposed right now in the name
of jesus
really seems like somebody might have
spiked the holy water with something
fierce there if you know what i'm saying
i think the most logical thing paula
white said there what wait what made the
most sense from those two clips
is when paula white said hamanda akata
rakata baka kanda ata
that i understood more than everything
else that went
on in that clip we have to be able to
call this
mental illness plain and simple right i
mean in other words
i know that there are people who will
say david it's offensive to say that
that's mental illness because this is
these are this is just religious belief
how is that not mental illness how is
that explain to me how it's not mental
illness
if anybody did that but didn't claim it
was their religion if you show up
and uh to a police station and you say
hamanda akata
you get a 72-hour cycle because she's
doing it in a church
with a mic and a guy with a bible behind
her we're supposed to just act like this
is normal guys we can't do it
we can't do it and if you're joe biden
you should worry with her doing that
i don't know that i mean that seems pat
what she's doing seems powerful i don't
know how biden can win anything with
that
look at the contrast okay she's talking
about
witchcraft with hamanda atta
and donald trump is trying to stop
ballots from being counted
rudy giuliani is filing six lawsuits
what joe biden said yesterday is
let's reduce the temperature i believe i
have a path to victory but i am not
declaring victory
and if i win i will be the president
for everybody every state red and blue
every american no matter whether you
voted for me
or you voted for donald trump or
somebody else we have never
seen a contrast greater than this in the
obama mccain
uh john kerry bush you know the these
these were
there were some bad candidates who did
some bad things and
advocated for bad policy there has never
been a contrast the likes of which we
are seeing right now
um we have a great bonus show for you
today you can
get the bonus show instantly by becoming
a member
at joinpakman.com new coupon code
fresh start all one word all lower case
you understand it
fresh start because that's what we hope
is coming here i'll see you on the bonus
show
so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video